one month ago a CBS News investigation
found child labor being used to mine
cobalt in the Democratic Republic of
Congo in Africa that mineral is
essential for the batteries in our
electronic devices we brought you the
story of one young miner whose only
dream was to go to school this morning
we have an update on his dreamed Debora
patta is in Johannesburg South Africa
Deborah good morning good morning in the
weeks following our investigation we
didn't hear from any of the companies
about changes to their supply chain but
we did hear from concerned viewers who
wanted to help and for one little boy
that was life changing we first met Zaki
Swasey here at a mine in the blistering
heat there he is with a Christmas
sweater on hard to miss at just 11 years
old he's one of an estimated 40,000
children in the DRC getting paid a
pittance to produce the cobalt that
powers our electronics every evening
Zeki an orphan returns home for the
dollar or two to provide for his
siblings and grandmother I feel very bad
because I can see my friends going to
schools aqui told us and I am struggling
when you go to sleep at night before you
go to sleep of that moment before you
fall asleep what do you think about
school he told us his only dream well
sometimes dreams do come true
now Zeki wears a uniform with a shiny
new backpack he's getting ready for
school for the very first time around 50
CBS this morning viewers were so moved
by Ziggy's plight they connected with
sister Catherine Burton D who through
the Good Shepherd project has saved over
a thousand children from the mines
enough money was raised to send not only
Ziggy
but his three siblings Ruth Emerson and
symmetry to school I would see the other
kids going to school and I would look at
them Ziggy said but today I feel the
happiness they feel and I'm now like
them
there were some first-day nerves he held
back tears outside the classroom but
sister Catherine was there to help it
wasn't long before Ziggy bravely stood
up and introduced himself to his new
classmates and joined the soccer team
the spotlight on Ziggy has changed the
lives of at least these children and
thanks to Ziggy maybe more if I become a
government minister he said I would ask
all the children who work in the mines
to go to school so that they could
become like me his new dream to help
other child miners Vicky is such a
remarkable boy that on the second day of
school just yesterday he arrived hours
early took of his shirt and cleaned the
classroom before the staff arrived the
good ship had now wants to raise funds
to send another 500 children just like
Ziggy to school John Debora patta in
South Africa Wow and 50 good shepherds
in our audience there's a lot of Ziggy's
like that in South Africa and when you
go there it is a children's dream they
just want to go to school and have a
uniform to do that that's such an
important story to tell we're glad he's
doing ok yeah daddy was doing great
Thank You Debra and thanks to people who
watch that story and do something yes
you know I mean the interaction that
they had to add I get it
thank goodness they did